goodness you've got so many briefs to
talk about haven't you this morning can
we start with a vaccine though first if
you may
um nh staff i'm nhs staff i'm told and
no longer
getting the vaccine first is that right
well look
uh the joint committee on vaccine
vaccinations and immunizations has set
out a priority list as you know
and that is based on uh the
vulnerability of someone to actually end
up being hospitalized and
all very sadly uh dying so we're going
to stick
with the prioritization that's been set
out
as i said that is done independently by
scientists and it's right and proper
that we follow that
but some of the confusion uh is around
the number of vaccines
that we can get originally 800 000 to
start with and then the prime minister's
saying
10 million by the end of the year but
that looks so it might not happen now
well
i mean 800 000 so we're starting the
program of course uh next week
uh as you know uh in uh hospitals are
getting ready for this
uh there'll be pods in gp surgeries as
well um so we're
starting initially with 800 000 and then
let's see where we end up by the end of
the year in terms of
the numbers that we acquire that will
depend on the manufacturing
uh i hope we will have some millions uh
by the end of this year but of course
what we also always said is that the
vast majority of this vaccinization
program
will take place in the new year
and of course uh okay the vaccine we're
currently talking about is the pfizer
biontech one
uh we also know that uh the astrazeneca
uh vaccine is currently under review by
the mhra
so we'll see what uh the they come
forward with on that
and of course we have acquired uh
further doses of that particular vaccine
yeah but why say
10 million and then not be able to
deliver why put a figure on it
well as i said i think look these are
this is a complex
vaccine that has to be stored at -70
degrees
uh i think it's right and proper that
all of that work is done properly
and we've always said that uh the bulk
of this stuff
will come in the new year i think we
should be very proud of the fact that
actually
as a country uh we were the first to uh
acquire this uh
this vaccine we were the first to uh
have it
pass through our regulator and of course
we'll be the first uh that would be
deploying
the vaccine but as i said uh the vast
majority of this program
will take place in the new year and that
is why people still need to observe
those basics
washing their hands exactly thank you
very much we know that dr anthony fauci
who you know the white house chief
immunologist told us yesterday that the
uk's approval
of the vaccine was done in a much less
deep
way than they would do it in the u.s um
how can you convince my viewers this
morning that it's safe if
the main man in the u.s is saying we've
rushed it well you should also see what
of course dr fashion subsequently said
overnight
about the fact that uh you know he is uh
confident in the processes that we have
followed and i just want to make this
point because you're absolutely right
this is about giving people the
confidence that the vaccine is safe
uh the mhra which is the regulator in
the uk is
uh independent uh it's also regarded
actually as a gold standard
of regulation by uh international
scientists people around the world
well as i said if you look at what he's
subsequently saying he said the f
the us's fda is the gold standard so i
was going to ask you what standard hours
well
as i've said to you i mean we regard uh
what we have got as a gold standard but
it's not just
us if you talk to the international
scientific community they will also say
that the mhra is the gold standard and
you will have heard in the last few days
from june rain
who runs the mhra who's made it very
clear that all the procedures have been
followed there have been no corners cut
so people should be really confident
that this vaccine is safe
if it wasn't safe it wouldn't be
deployed and i certainly have full
confidence in the work that the mhra
have done so dr fatchi is wrong when he
says that the fda in the us is the gold
standard
well as i said i mean i can only talk
for the regulator that we have
in this country and i i know i would
encourage you to get scientists in uh
who will tell you
we do well well great i mean should gets
some more later on and they will tell
you that the mhra
is indeed a gold standard um we did hear
from gavin williamson he was not just
where you are uh
arrived this time yesterday um and he
was talking about um
our vaccine uh uh being much better
because our scientists are much better
than those in france belgium or the us
why would he say that well look i mean
i've seen some of the
the the uh well look i mean
you know there was a an element of
tongue-in-cheek about it but i think he
was making
a more fundamental point which is
actually we should be really proud
of what we as a as a country have
achieved uh in terms of the number of
vaccine doses that we've acquired
the vaccines task force sits in my
department they have done heroic work
this is civil servants this is uh people
from the the business community the
pharmaceutical
companies all coming together to ensure
that we have almost 360 million
doses of seven of the the most promising
vaccine candidates across the world i
think that's something we should be
proud of
so how many have arrived so far i think
as uh
i said to you i think we will uh uh uh
be deploying this next week so we we
will at that point have about eight
hundred thousand
as we speak uh well it'll be um
uh close to eight hundred thousand i
said we we start
uh the deployment from next week uh and
by that point we will have the full
eight hundred thousand this is precious
cargo um how do we transport it does it
have like a police escort is that is it
what's the security like well
it it is i don't want to go into the
details of that okay but
i mean it is of course it is done in a a
secure
manner i think that's right and proper
uh so yes i can confirm that this is
done in a very secure way
okay and out there in the country most
of them already that we need of those
eight hundred thousand to start the
rollout next well we're starting next
week so uh yes you would hope so and i
think it takes a while doesn't it for it
to actually settle before you can give
them the
vaccination um how much is it all
costing
uh well actually uh you know all the
contracts all of that will be sort of
set out there's a there's a
as you know there's a process for doing
all of that when it comes to government
contracts
um we haven't set that out at this stage
i think
there is an issue of you know commercial
confidentiality about some of this but
as i said
in due course people will be able to see
this what i would say to you
and i think um you know as we start this
vaccination program as we roll it out
across the country more and more people
get it
and we are able to get back to some
semblance of normality open up
the economy fully i i mean what i would
say to you is that
the cost of these these vaccines is
going to be dwarfed
by the economic benefit to the country
and in fact
people's well-being as well as a result
of making sure that we've got vaccines
being deployed
supermarket tax relief um the
supermarkets are paying back 1.8 billion
i believe
from the business rate holiday should
that go to help pay for the vaccines or
should that go to help struggling pubs
uh well uh you know we we've made uh 280
billion pounds available to support
people's jobs support businesses and
livelihoods
uh over the past few months and since we
talked about the hospitality sector
uh and and pubs uh i'm not gonna ask you
about scotch eggs oh well
you're you're you're welcome to but uh
actually i'm vegetarian so
i'd probably be not gonna be able to eat
but but uh when it comes to the
hospitality sector
of course they have got a business rates
holiday uh
we've also ensured that vat has been
temporarily cut
they have also received grants and of
course you have seen the furlough scheme
extended until
march and for businesses that are either
required to be closed because of the
restrictions we have in tier three
they're able to claim
up to 3 000 pounds a month each
and actually even for businesses that uh
have facing some restrictions but still
able to open in some way
in tier two uh they will be able to
claim up to 2100 pounds
so there is support that has been made
available yeah but we
both know that hundreds of thousands of
jobs are at risk in the hospitality
industry and
unless they get more money well uh look
i i
completely understand that it is a very
very difficult time for the hospitality
sector
uh for actually lots of sectors across
the economy i talk to businesses
every day so i very much feel that
burden on my shoulders
but as i said we are providing support
but the best thing we can possibly do
is to get the economy fully opened up
and the way we do that is by getting the
r8 down
and you know there is room for optimism
we've talked about the vaccine
we've also got the rapid testing that is
being deployed we've seen that that
works as well
so there is room here for cautious
optimism but for the moment
exactly as you said people need to
observe those basics
wash your hands cover your face and
maintain social distancing um brexit
uh are we gonna do a deal this weekend
um well
we are uh of course uh in those uh
discussions uh we are still having those
discussions but it is
fair to say that we are in a difficult
phase there are some tricky issues still
to be resolved
and i would just say this point which is
that right from the start of this
process okay
i'm sure i've been on your program
talked about this over the past many
months
we've always said that a deal can only
be done
if the eu recognizes that the uk is a
sovereign independent nation
it is on the basis of that that a deal
will be done but i said we continue to
have those tools both sides to make a
deal though
sure but as i said this has been a key
principle for us
that the uk is that the uk is a
sovereign nation well well
i mean obviously people talk about
fisheries their issues around level
playing field
you you'll forgive me if i particularly
since we're at such a sensitive time
these discussions i'm not going to get
into
the precise details of uh those
discussions
uh but you know we are at a critical
phase given that we're at a critical
face and you're aware of it i understand
why you can't play your hand
at this stage on television but can you
give me a percentage chance of whether
we'll be able to have a deal by the end
of
it has to be done by sunday because
there's all sorts of stuff without going
into too much detail
and getting down in the weeds the stuff
going on in the house it comes on monday
and tuesday
that means that you'll have to have a
deal or not by sunday night
well look i've never been a betting man
myself so i'm not going to get into the
percentages
game all i can say to you is that david
frost and his team
are working incredibly hard we are doing
this in good faith
but ultimately there has to be recognize
recognition that we are a sovereign
nation
you're here to talk about climate and
2050 um
we should be carbon neutral by 2050.
that's a very ambitious target how
confident are you
i'm not asking for percentages because
you're not a betting man no no but i
will give you some percentages oh you
will understand
some percentages because what we've
shown as
a country is that we actually have been
able to cut emissions
and grow our economy at the same time
and i was on your program a couple of
weeks ago talking about this 10-point
plan
the green industrial revolution and that
is driving forward
creating jobs uh creating wealth in our
country but at the same time cutting
emissions over the last 30 years
uh as a country we have managed to cut
emissions by 43 percent
but at the same time grow our economy by
75 so as a country we have shown
and actually we're world leading at this
uh you know we were the first major
economy which
has legislated for net zero by 2050 uh
and
uh uh you know of all the g7 nations uh
we have shown the fastest cutting
emissions since 1990.
uh we've got this climate ambition
summit that is taking place on the 12th
of december
we hope that other countries will come
forward with ambitious uh emissions
targets
um but you know let's see where we go
but certainly it's been really important
for the prime minister particularly
is that we put our best foot forward and
i think it's been recognized that uh
the plans that we have are really pretty
ambitious now i'm very worried about you
because i hear that you're spinning too
many plates and now you're president of
the
cop 26 climate conference as well have
you just got too much on
well actually uh since we talk about my
role at uh
at cop uh over the past few months i've
had bilateral meetings with
ministers in 40 countries i've spoken at
almost 50
international gatherings and events and
at the same time of course i've
managed to do my my role as business
secretary um you know
my approach always in these things is to
keep your head down do your job
uh and if you do that uh you know things
will
will happen okay just before i let you
go um
for the benefit of my viewers uh at home
this morning um jonathan van tam i
guarantee
that father christmas will be one of the
first people to get the vaccine
i checked and he's 1700 years old
so is it true what do you get what is he
one of the first to get back
well i think on the prioritization he
would clearly be at the top of the list
okay so
that's a yes isn't it for all my younger
viewers watching this absolutely that's
right
christmas is going to be fine guys is
top of the list it's top of the list
fantastic you heard it here first on sky
thank you for joining us